I'd wanted to open with some sort of
quote that had the name bill in it but
all I could think of was Kill Bill
quotes and that didn't feel appropriate
okay so I kind of wanted to do this
video a week ago except that I had only
just put out my sort of overview of my
thoughts on politics and Doctor Who at
that point I wanted to get a fun Doctor
Who video in between then and not just
jump right back into this but going by
the title you can probably guess I'm
gonna be dealing that same sort of area
talking about similar things so I'm
gonna narrow the focus a bit more than
last time as I had kind of anticipated
there were a fair number of comments on
my last video about politics in Doctor
Who that when someone give the effect of
okay I accept the political messaging
has always been a part of Doctor Who but
more recent seasons more recent series
of the show have been doing it more
frequently and with less subtlety than
they used to and a high percentage of
the people expressing that sentiment
would very swiftly point to the
character of Bill from series 10 as
their prime example of this because
within a certain segment of Doctor Who
fandom there is a perception that Bill
exists to push a specific politically
minded agenda in regards to both her
race and especially her sexuality and
it's that second one that I'm going to
address more specifically here now
before I get into it I do want to sort
of lay out that my intention here is
pretty much the same as it was last time
I talked about politics and Doctor Who
which is I want to address a fallacy
that I keep seeing coming up in
arguments over and over and over again
and I also want to be clear that my
picking apart this specific issue does
not negate all arguments that are saying
that politics may be handled clumsily or
other things of that nature I'm dealing
specifically with this claim about Bill
as an agenda pushing companion and the
reason I want to deal with it is because
I like these discussions when they
happen but I keep seeing this get
brought up and then it derails the
discussion because people you know
either try and take this fallacy apart
they try and defend it it gets hung up
on it or people who say it will say this
and now follow up as if this itself as a
smoking gun and just bringing up the
character of Bill somehow ends the
argument so having now
that and very clearly tipped my hand as
to where I'm gonna be going with this I
hope you'll still stick with me even if
you're inclined to disagree with me and
at least hear me out now before I get
into it I am gonna have to give a rather
substantial amount of credit to the
redditor Clint biruni because they did
some research and put up a post on the
Doctor Who subreddit which I'll be
linking in the description that really
that work that they did is the backbone
of what I'm gonna talk about I am gonna
move past just what they laid out but it
is pretty fundamental to what I'm gonna
be saying and I feel it's important to
acknowledge somebody else's contribution
to this conversation so what happened
was that they did a breakdown of each
time the primary companion affirmed
their sexuality because if you're gonna
make the claim that every time bill
mentions that she prefers women talks
about having a crush on a girl or says
that a female character is cute and
claimed that that's some sort of
affirmation of her homosexuality well
then you kind of have to accept that any
time any of the other companions talk
about a boyfriend they used to have or
point out that a male character is cute
that is an affirmation of their
heterosexuality so Clint biruni compared
and put together data for how many
episodes across their entire appearances
in the show up to this point each
companion actually did that and what
actually comparing them the findings are
pretty clear-cut so as of this recording
bill has made some sort of affirmation
of her homosexuality in seven out of her
12 appearances that she's had so far now
that sounds pretty bad that's more than
half that's 50% if we're going to get
pretty specific about it but she's not
the companion with the most references
to her sexual preference she's actually
not even close the one with the most is
Amy she did it in 87 percent of the
episode she appeared in now to a certain
degree that's not a huge surprise
because she was in some form of
relationship for her entire stint as a
companion and for a good chunk of that
her partner and eventual husband was
actually traveling with her so it's not
a huge surprise that it came up more
often for her than anybody else but then
we go down the list and the next one up
is Rose who had it
Princeton 77% of her appearances next up
is Clara who just edges out bill with
60% and then coming underneath bill we
have Martha and Donna with 57 and 43%
respectively so bill actually falls
pretty comfortably in the middle as far
as how frequently her sexual preference
gets referenced now also touch briefly
that the original post went even a
little bit deeper and broke down what
they called inclusions now an inclusion
as opposed to a mere reference an
inclusion is any time that they are seen
with or directly communicating with a
clear-cut or very clear perspective love
interest for them and I'm not gonna do
the whole breakdown like you just did
but know that bill falls in the same
place she had fewer inclusions then Amy
rose or Clara but more than Martha or
Donna again right in the middle so if
Bill isn't actually bringing up her
sexual preferences more often than other
companions are why does it feel like she
does because I want to be very clear I
don't think that people who are making
the claim that oh she keeps bringing it
up all the time
I don't think they're trying to be
deceptive about it I think for them they
do honestly feel that and this feeling
is true and I'm not gonna sit here and
just break them lingo you're feeling is
backed up by data therefore you have no
right to feel that no I would rather
just explore and look at why would that
feeling be the case if the numbers don't
back it up and what that has to do with
is normalization because to be blunt
about it most of us don't notice
references that people make to
heterosexual relationships because it
happens so often not only in
entertainment but in our everyday lives
it's totally normal and it doesn't it
doesn't pain your radar you don't take
notice of each individual time it
happens however for the vast majority of
people references to homosexuality are
exceptions they are deviations from what
they're used to so you notice each time
it happens and when something that
strikes us as uncommon or out of place
happens more than a few times it creates
a disproportionate
sense of happening all the time even
though that is not actually the truth
it's just that our sort of radar is
getting pinged more often than we're
used to on this thing so to sort of
illustrate that a little bit I'm gonna
pull one of my favorite quotes from Red
Dwarf and it's a scene where the
character of Rimmer has just heard the
captain's remarks on his file and the
captain made reference to the fact that
the character has constantly failed the
engineering exam and what Rimmer says is
one would hardly call 11 times
constantly I mean if someone ate roast
beef 11 times in their life you would
hardly say that person constantly ate
roast beef no it would be a rare nay
freak occurrence and I like that because
a it's a good joke but B it does also
illustrate the point because of course
that one would feel that way about
eating roast beef because eating roast
beef is a very common easily understood
thing that it's an everyday occurrence
failing the exact same exam in in a
continuous fashion that is not as common
occurence and it's going to make it seem
like it's happening constantly and the
simple truth is that for the majority of
viewers homosexuality and references to
it are the exception and not the rule
and that has nothing to do with
prejudice or bigotry
that's just statistical fact a very high
percentage of the population run into
members of the LGBTQ community
infrequently enough that each time it
happens it is worth noting because it's
not normalized yet and therefore so is
any reference to that same community
that comes across in the entertainment
consumed by those same people so again
every time it's brought up it pings your
radar in a way that references to
heterosexual relationships just doesn't
do so that tackles the raw numbers but I
also want to address the conception that
the times that Bill does mention her
homosexuality and her preference for
women that it comes across as somehow
extremely forced or crowbarred in
because that's the other aspect that
people who like to bring bill up in the
argument use as the supposed smoking gun
this idea that there's no way a normal
person will be bringing this up in the
ways at the time she does that's how we
know it's crowbar Dean and pushing an
agenda so setting aside whether or not
the simple confirmation that a gay
person exists in a fictional world
should be taken as a political thing in
the first place seems as it's not a
belief system like someone repeatedly
bringing up the fact that they are
atheist or vegan or a socialist or well
but I'm tangent and getting off setting
that aside I just feel that this view
that bill is forcing this information
into the conversation where it doesn't
fit normally is very much skewed by
perspective because the people who make
this claim I would be willing to bet the
logic follows that well I don't have to
constantly tell people that I'm straight
why is she always bringing up the fact
that she's gay but the thing is the two
experiences don't equate because the
default assumption for most of us is
when we encounter someone who we haven't
met before that they are going to be
straight because again just raw numbers
statistically speaking that assumption
is correct more often than it is
incorrect but what that means is if you
are straight you've never really had to
affirm that fact to anybody because it's
the default assumption already being
made about you but it's also the
assumption being made about Bill but in
her case it's an incorrect assumption
and despite the way that people like to
mock how they think or to have chosen to
remember Bill's interactions going she
doesn't actually meet someone for the
first time ago hi nice to meet you I'm
bill and I like girls know what actually
tends to happen is when something
happens or something is said or
expressed by someone who she has only
recently met that indicates that they
believe her to be straight she quickly
steps in and clarifies actually I prefer
women she addresses it as it comes up
and then she moves on and this speaks to
a very real truth for many members of
the LGBTQ community because again the
default assumption when you encounter
someone new unless there's something
very obvious stating otherwise you
assume heterosexual cisgender and if
those are not the case for you you need
to be prepared to ideally politely which
I think bill does in every case just
point out okay you assume to this about
me it's actually not true it's this okay
let's go let's move on from there and if
you want a comparison to make on that
think about the times that the doctor
and Donna in series four had to clarify
to people that the two of
were not a couple they didn't introduce
themselves to people hi I'm the doctor
this is Donna we're not together rather
they would introduce themselves to
people I'm the doctor this is Donna and
if they saw that that person assumed
they were together they do that little
look to each other go Oh actually were
not a couple
it's the same principle they address it
as it comes up and while this may seem
unnatural to someone who does not on a
regular basis have to affirm what their
sexual preferences are because they
match the default just imagine any false
assumption that someone could be making
about you on a regular basis when when
it becomes clear that they'd made that
false assumption you address it then and
that's what bill does and I don't think
there's anything unnatural or crowbarred
or forced in about that now as I get to
the tail end of this thing I do want to
emphasize again this video had a very
narrow focus and that is for a reason
and while I hope that I've been able to
point out the flaws in this particular
takedown of this particular character I
want to re-emphasize the fact that I'm
not saying that that means all
criticisms on the bluntness of certain
political messages are invalid nor that
bill herself is somehow an infallible
character above any criticism there's a
reason that I end every video with an
invitation to comment so we can actually
talk about this I enjoy discussion I
like hearing views that aren't mine and
there are certainly points to be made
there are times that political messaging
in doctor who has the subtlety of a
brick to the face and as much as I may
love an episode like say oxygen I can at
the same time admit that it probably
would have been a little bit better if
it had just let the undercurrent of
extreme capitalism in its criticism of
that be a subtext pretty clear subtext
level just by how this story was
structured out but it was not necessary
to actually call out capitalism by name
and doing so didn't really add anything
to the story but there are a few things
that derail good discussion good debate
like a getting hung up on a fallacy
either by one side having to address
something that is demonstrably untrue or
another site just dropping it as if it
ends the argument and again I don't want
to invalidate anyone's feelings about
how often they fell like bill was
presenting these things but I'm hoping
that even those folks can look at what
talked about and look into it further
themselves if they wish to and
understand that their feeling of how
often it happened is not in proportion
to what was actually going on so that's
about it I wish I could say that I'm
done talking about political issues in
Doctor Who for a while I'm not gonna
promise that because there's the
distinct possibility something will
happen in the comments that will spur on
another train of thought or something
else could happen that I'll feel the
need to talk about so I'm not gonna make
any promises what I will say it is my
hope to not have to talk about politics
and Doctor Who again for a while we'll
see what happens so what are your
thoughts on all of this whatever they
are and please do keep them civil I love
good I love conversation but a good part
of any conversation is being civil about
it but if you can do that please whether
you agree with me or not drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at Council of geeks give
a listen to the council of geeks podcast
feed available on iTunes and stitcher
I'm also one half of the punch like a
girl podcast which will be on the fire
and water Network starting in October
give those a listen and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]